hi
i'm alex after some talks about applying
ai
it's time to look at the handcraft of
making data science happen
people ask me how did you become such a
good programmer and my answer is i
wanted to focus on getting
results and insight from data people
look surprised that i'd like to point
out
programming not being a self-serving
purpose we built software to general
value
and i was always interested in data and
getting the data right actually was a
big driver in getting the programming
right as well
so today i'm happy to share some of my
expertise in this matter in this
short talk so
let me introduce myself
my name is alexander ahmednov i'm a
managing partner and principal
consultant
for data science and ai at konigsbig i'm
a software foundation fellow
i'm a soft python software for band
chair which is four stunt and i'm an
organizer of pi condition pi data berlin
also i run two local combinator
communities here
with other organizers all around in the
area
you can find me on twitter github or
linkedin
feel free to add me ping me follow me on
viewage let me tell you a little bit
more about quinnix week
physics week is a boutique consultancy
we enable
enterprises for data science and ai at
kunix week business and tech teams work
together to make data science and iii
happen
i see beginners of all ages from
university
and clients i see seasoned developers
and i work a lot with the community
we work in small dedicated teams and
love to do this with freeland expert
experts
this is an example from pi data
frankfurt
and this is an example from pi data
zoodles so whenever you're in the area
you want to give a talk we can travel
again and
just ping me we're happy to have as you
see
speakers from all around around
also watch out for the forthcoming
piconde and pi data berlin
in 2021 which will happen in october
at the pcc high in berlin
so today we're going to um
talk about better code for data science
and but the whole data science
making data science happen and how in
includes many different aspects so it
includes communication
to stakeholders engineering our topic
today
ethics value and resources and
what do you want to accomplish we want
productive extendable solutions for
inside decision-making
support maybe even some wisdom
often it's unclear how to launch data
science in a given structure
in a department sometimes
people are just struggling how to get
started and how to get productive
because very often they don't
they lack some the first some of the
perspectives i want to provide you today
unfortunately the engineering part is
often not well understood
or like appreciated um some industries
from experience understand better
nowadays
but the question is if you want to get
data science
and ai started ask yourself where do we
actually
stand because it's not just like
some notebooks and it's not just getting
a data science working student
there is much more to add
or to bring to the table to really make
it happen so
let's start with a little question
answering game
um like it's that you probably might
know from the show what's my line
i didn't know it i just saw it on
youtube it's
from the 60s so but anyway
um let's have some blindfolded people
asking
questions
first question why do programming stills
matter
for one quality assurance as you know
quality matters especially in
engineering um
and we want to trust data and
predictions we get as much as we can so
there shouldn't be any flaws in the code
making
wrong predictions so we want to focus
on value on not fighting bugs so
and also it's important to understand
um good programming skills matter
research shows that the gap between
programmers can be
up to a factor of like 10 in
productivity
and that unskilled and experienced
programmers
can even slow projects down
so it's very important to understand
where your team's at what they can do
what they can't
and where they probably need support
from the inside or from the outside
talking about humans humans produce code
so
let's have a little closer look on
personas i've met
there are many ways to become a data
scientist today
for one ask yourself who might you be
combinations welcome
and taking all these different
backgrounds
respectfully into account is important
for building healthy effective teams
including ways to have the best
contribution for
everyone and these are just
engineering personas there are also
project number managers product owners
and other stakeholders to take into
account
depending on your organization so as you
see from the personas
there are many some personas are like
super excited about the latest and new
stuff
and some more skeptical personas and
it's important to understand
each of them their perspectives because
they can bring a lot of value to the
table as well
but you'll also have to see it's a quite
it can be something like a quite
colorful mix
and that's something you have to take to
take into account as well
um to keep your projects on track
so a team works better having a common
workflow
if you're just one person few or many
decide on how may how we want to work
together and do not change workflows
constantly if there's not a good reason
so just a new tool is not a good reason
routines help to stay focused and on
track
um you might be surprised to see
no tools here because i don't want to
recommend any tools here
because it often depends on what's in
place already
and we can build around it and of course
there is never a perfect tool chain
at comics week we are helping often we
often helping
to make the right calls here to make
decisions
and yeah to get things going here
and how should we set up our code
so that's like pretty broad questions
and i want to answer with like
coding architecture and stack
and let's go let's have some principles
so
the first principles actually there's a
lot of principles already set out in
pep20 design of python
so uh it's in it's building in python
you just have to import this
um it's very nice to read and i can
really recommend sometimes if you're
stuck go back just import this um
read through and probably it will might
provide good solution and the zen of
both phone is
looks like a hoax but actually there's a
lot of truth in there
for the design principles and how to
write good code just like
few examples like beautiful's better
knackly explicit is better than in
placing
simple is better than complex but
complex is better than complicated
readability counts you are just like
some highlights
and of course you need an architecture
architecture is the way we have our
services and software interact
as with workflows there is not one
architecture to solve all
but the team has to agree on one
architecture to start with
and of course this architecture has not
to be
fully elaborated from the very beginning
it can evolve with the project
new needs identified but it's important
to have a vision where you want to move
with your architecture
because otherwise um you end up probably
having many individual architectures and
they usually don't detect that well
and also you want to stay independent so
avoid property property services for
example of cloud providers
because they make you like stick with
people with
like some companies and you probably
want to move somewhere else or
use our different architectures in the
future so
it's it's really it's always good to
stay independent
and although sometimes it might be a
short route to take
and of course the stack what do i mean
with stack stack is like
libraries we use and the frameworks
and and there it is likely as we work
with state-of-the-art technology we look
for new technology as curious as we are
and things like this happen oh sort is
possible this framework
and your colleague might say hey i have
this new framework over here and we
should really try this out
because new frameworks always promise
to be better than the current framework
because you haven't used them yet you
and no pain
no trouble they're fresh and perfect
at least as it seems so
so um it's important not to end up in
discussions like this okay there's a new
framework should we switch of course
it's important to stay agile and there
might be good reasons to change
frameworks and libraries in a running
project even an early stage or any stage
but it has to be like a really
well informed decisions so give it a try
if
things really work switch otherwise it's
not just about having a new framework
so the stock where software stack should
be defined minimal
and stable what i mean with that is
don't add new stuff
all the time because
the more you add the more complicated
things will get
and it's impossible to manage
but set up everything for
experimentation and keep things
extendable
and of course a good way before looking
at new libraries from the outside
there's the python standard library and
it comes with python with many useful
libraries
and it's yeah you can do a lot of great
things with that
just have a look at david beasley's
keynote built in superheroes from pi
data chicago
he does a whole data science project
using the python standard library
exclusively
it's a great talk to watch and it's a
great talk to learn about all these
libraries
and how they can make your life easier
without getting any external
dependencies
environments environments are spaces to
program within
last time i checked i had 45 of them on
just like one my comp on
one of my computers but very often they
are not like super interested it's
interesting so people
don't talk about that much but i see
many people especially beginners
struggle with like how can i have my
working environment set up what's this
what is this what is this an environment
variable
and all these config files from all
these libraries and programs
in all these different places um how can
i manage everything with conda pip
and how can i do this in a reproducible
fashion
this is something you really
have to spend some time on and to get
into it and help
your team to to work with that because
it's it's a big
productivity factor and of course if you
want to try something new just clone
your existing environment and
try it out and don't put all the new
stuff in your working environment which
is
actually working and productive
so and oops that's the wrong one so here
we go
so this is just like an example of some
environments
set up in your shell if you haven't seen
that before
but we cannot go into detail in this
short talk
so you might be surprised to see all
these other factors in this talk here
but i think it's important to point out
it it's a package and
not just like the coding but now let's
go to the coding and let me introduce
you to spaghetti code
spaghetti code is defined as things that
work it's unclear how the code parts
actually interact or
con how they are connected and once you
want
to cut it into smaller pieces um the
connections
get lost and everything falls apart the
code becomes
unmaintainable very often people have to
start from scratch
then and um often spaghetti code is
built in prototypes somebody who just
wants to try something out and he's not
a very skilled programmer but got things
working
in a way with a lot of stack overflow
and things
and it's the absolute empty pattern
so what makes good good code or bad
so good code should be readable
maintainable
shareable reliable and documented so
readable well chosen concise names and
wording
maintainable meals well structure easy
to understand
from the outside so not from people who
work
on it all the time somebody who is
pretty new to the project should be
easy to get get into the project by just
like
reading it and finding all this nicely
um structured code shareable
your colleagues um should not only to be
read to able to read it so but it should
be
should not contain like secrets there so
keep secrets private and shareable the
other dimension of
sharepoint maybe your colleagues in
another department want to use it as
well
so it should be also like reusable so
try to abstract your business logic if
possible
um and think about people can save a lot
of time
uh if they can reuse your code open
source it's all built on that
and of course code has to be reliable
well tests and exception handling and
documentation
we'll see in a bit
so code readability um code readability
it's a lot of work it's not just
something that comes with writing code
um it's actually it takes some time to
come up with concise descriptive names
good code should not need a lot of
documentation because
of the variables of the functions and
classes if they have like really nice
names
um the better names the less
documentation
you will need because the cone code
basically explains
itself and so
keep it concise split long lines keep it
readable
sorry life talks um
break very complex along into smaller
functions
so don't try like build walls of code
like split them in smaller pieces if you
can
abstraction is king here or queen
and add line comments to write context
but not explain the obvious
so don't say this is a for loop doing
something because people reading the
code
expect them to actually know python and
yeah and also it should be linted
especially in teams
um like auto pap black there are many
other tools around
to they can help you to link your code
to have like a certain standard
or like the same standard within your
team or even your organization i think
this is very important
and define your own style guide for
stability
because there's a lot of style guys
around but you might want to adapt
some rules to your requirements but
everybody in your team should stick to
them
for example data classes now
be explicit if more than one return
value what does it mean so if you have
like one more than one return value for
a function
you don't really want to work with
indexes and for example data classes
provide a great way to do this and
let's just show you let me show you
encode here
so here we have just like a data class
it's uh it was introduced in python 3
7 or 8 i guess um and this is how
a data class is basically a python class
with benefits and specialized in data
that's all
to it so they're really easy to define
so all you have to do is add
the decorator as data class
here and um and uh
build a title and uh for example here we
do a pie data global talk
so this is basically all you need for
the data class i added some extra stuff
like the post in it which is
unknown because data classes already
have in it so there's this special post
in it here
where we can add some extra value and we
can also have like extra functions
here all methods um so if we have a talk
for
pi data global talk and we have this as
a return value
it's really handy because we can access
data classes with attributes
um before you probably heard of named
pupils
they're very similar but data classes
are
way better and that's it's really fun to
use them sorry
for example here this is the duration in
seconds
we just put this as a convenience
function in the post in it
i think you get the idea so
data classes are great for that
let's go back to here
so what makes code maintainable um a
consistent style and
consistent approaches now and i think
this is one of the hardest parts
if different people work together
everybody has like their own style
sometimes people want to try something
new but
um also in bigger teams people
sometimes leave new people join the team
and you really want
the consistency and the consistency of
approaches as well
is helping them to get into the code
to become productive so um
code should be self-explanatory and it's
very important to follow the dry
principles so trying means don't repeat
yourself
you can also rephrase this there should
be only a single point of failure so if
you have to change something
in your code it should be at one point
and one point only
and not at like five points uh because
if there are five points i guarantee it
will be changing four points and you
have like really odd behavior and a lot
of bug fighting until you find
the fifth place with the code so this is
very important and
this happens very often in data science
that with copy and paste we have a lot
of redundancy
and many um and do not really follow the
price the drive principle
and it's a big time saver too if you
want to be productive
and of course tests
and also important part is how can i
share my code so i think
it is state of the art i know few people
who
do not use git um commit often
use a repository or a service like
github or gitlab
and put like your secrets in getting
notified so they don't
get hurt and come up with guidelines
how to make pull requests and have teams
review your code because it's good to
learn from each other
and how it's odd to maybe criticize or
comment
on colleagues code
which is not according to the style
guide but i think it's an important
process
so everybody can learn everybody can
contribute and
yeah it's it's it's it's like a
super good way to get things going and
um
to produce ah nice code together
you can also go as far as continuous
integration on the
deployment with auto tests and
publishing but that's a nice to have
it's really nice to have but
it's not necessary in the first in the
beginning
and last the reliability of course
testing
because your code has to be reliable the
systems you work with
are not reliable and your code really
should handle that
and and so i think it's very good to use
explicit exception
handling to make your code reliable and
handle
other unreliable things that might
happen all around you
or your code and you can add tie pins
to uh help your ide to um
interpret your code better and also
simplicity
is really important to make it reliable
because
simple is like better to maintain easier
to
find any bugs or odd behavior
compared to really complicated stuff
so and what does documented mean of
course documented
and documentation can easily take like
20 25
of the time so it's it's not just like a
nice to have
you can do on the site it's something
you have to do constantly
you should really write read me dark
strengths line comments
to explain what's going on and have
working example codes
like little as little tutorials always
think okay there's somebody who has no
clue about
the code you wrote and you want to bring
somebody on board in a
short period of time so um
it's it's it's very important and very
often it's
overlooked and then many people have to
spend a lot of time to understand your
code or
might end up in writing something new or
similar because they don't
really get it um so good documentation
is
uh is of this is super important and
i can only advise spend the time and if
somebody
does not value it and you don't have to
then fight for this time it's
really important otherwise the code
might be yeah lost or not
no long no longer understandable
of course you have to update
documentation and refactor it
all the time the code changes
documentation has to go along with that
another nice thing in python is
know when to break the rules um the only
thing i want to point out is
um the rule the reason has to relate to
the project and not to
personal reasons as i was in a hurry or
i was late
so if you have a good reason be explicit
about it and
feel free to break rules in the comments
it's a good practice from time to time
not all the time probably
so is that it no of course it's not
because we haven't talked about bringing
jupyter notebooks to production yet
so what about jupyter lab exploratory
data analysis
exploratory code execution as i want to
call it
it's open source it comes with
visualization formats
markdown text ecosystem it's great i
love it i use it
every day so but what about this
um this is a tweet from andrew kapathi
and this is the director of artificial
intelligence and autopilot vision at
tesla and basically to sum it up he's on
complaining on
twitter that he deleted something from
his jupiter notebook
he was working on for two months and
he deleted something and he wanted to
undelete it and he was struggling
so i don't really want to comment this
further because i
think it explains myself and i'm
maybe not feeling that comfortable with
tesla currency
anyway kidding yeah so but here i mean
see this is like this is not just like
anybody
yeah so this is like tesla should be a
company who should
really be very good at engineering
because they build
to build autonomous vehicles so
one of the downsides of notebooks code
competition is not as good as an ids
they take some more time then
jupiter is not pointing to code smells
code versioning is quite hard
notebooks are scripts the execution
order matters
introspection and debugging is not
really solved yet
so when
data artist salvador dali was asked in
our show to make like a gesture
from his day-to-day job he was moving
his hand so
like painting but somebody jumped to a
conclusion oh it's easy you're a data
scientist who's scrolling notebooks all
the time
all day and i think um yeah this is
one of the common anti-patterns in um
jupiter notebooks because jupiter
notebooks very often
they have a wall of code they have
non-local variables which will i explain
in a minute
they often have redundancies and they
just
explain something or they just like get
something to work
which is very it's it's okay if it's
like a tutorial if you want to just
explain or try something out
but these things fail if you really want
to bring something to a production
so what's wall of code
what can you do about it actually you
can first thing you consider just
multiple cells and not built like these
monster cells
um but you can break down little bits of
your code also
into functions also especially the
redundant part
you should really break the redundant
parts into functions and
just apply the functions and you even if
you have like bigger functions you can
break them into multiple functions as
well
and if you really want to get a little
bit further
you can also build a class with
and you put all these functions into the
class and then
just have a class and then like the
class can provide you with an object
the object objects can easily store data
attributes parameters whatever you want
and you can have these functions now
called methods because they're in a
class on on the data
and and and and in the final step you
can
put all this in a module just like next
to your notebook
and you can basically remove almost all
the code
from your notebook and
what about all these non-local variables
because they can be like really
yeah they they are really hard to
refactor
because you cannot move the code because
they depend on something from the
outside
so just let me let me show you
this is a simple example of an example
jupiter notebook
we define two variables by and a by
constant
above here and then we have some a
little bit of code and
stuff and somewhere down here below
we want to apply um these various we
need to use them
so if we want we use them in my funk
here
um we just pass in a new value and
return multime bye bye
so do you really remember what buy was
and
are you sure it was not changed
somewhere in between as well
um so of course this is working
here still um but you can another
approach is actually just like to put it
as a parameter and pass it on and i
think this is the
right way um it things should
should be done because the variable is
not
looked oh i should put this here
it's not looked outside so of course
variables are local within functions
unless the name is not found in the
local
function namespace then python goes to
the global namespace
and looks for names here for a good
reason because
you can it's a good way to
add constants for example we can put the
by constant here
constants are written in uppercase
although they are variables um
and and also use them in functions or as
a parameter
uh default as we see here
so let's go back to here
so you see these are really hard to
transport and it can be
really like a lot of work to build a
notebook with like many of them i've
seen like many of them
okay that so and redundancies yeah and
then this is
especially a really easy answer just
avoid them use functions
always remember the dry principle even
if getting here is a little bit
more of extra work but in the long run
you really will appreciate this
so and what about debugging so python is
really good in introspection so python
is very open nothing's really hidden
we can really look into the code and the
execution stack and every
frame and see what's going on and have a
look at the values
and um and ids actually provide good
debuggers and introspection so
we'll get there in a second um i think
also print statements are okay
for debugging and especially at earliest
page if you just want to understand
let's go there of course but think about
logging is better you can write log
files to file and guess what
there's a login module in the python
standard library which is easy to set up
and use
so let's have a look at debuggers
so here we see a debugger some code
and we see these these red dots are
stock marks
so basically just executing my code in
debug mode and the code stops
at the stop mark
and then the nice thing here is i can
really inspect
what's going on here so if you ever
wanted to look have a little closer look
at your vgg g16 and pytorch
it's really easy to do also because it's
by charge by charge is very pythonic
and you have all these objects you can
inspect
so if you want to for example have a
closer look
at the the bias data from two
of them layers and you want to have some
reason to multiply them
you can just do it by evaluating the
code in
in a separate window or you can inspect
it
in the window you see behind a good part
also about
having this evaluate window and working
in debug mode you can immediately
write new code snippets and basically
test them
while coding i call this like coding and
the open heart
basically like it's like an operation on
the open heart it's a saying in german
and i think this explains really good
you can basically
interfere with your code while the
program is actually running and i think
this is this is like super productive to
get new code
written and you can avoid like a lot of
like
small mistakes because you immediately
see the results and if you have
whatever you have in mind is actually
working or if there's a tiny bit to fix
so i my suggestion is to use jupiter and
an ide
and just take best of both worlds it's
the best way to be
get productive in data science and just
focus on the strong
suits of both
and then the question is how can i have
shorter concise notebooks
so i already explained a bit like you
can put stuff in functions we can
build classes with functions we can put
them in modules
and we can use magics like the run magic
to get
stuff into our notebooks for example and
i think a good practice or it depends of
course in the use case
but i know many use cases where people
are not really interested in seeing
all of the all the code in in in the
notebooks they basically want to see
results they want to see with your
realization and maybe
you just want to see like a key part of
something you invented a new methodology
but you don't really want to see like
how to read in data
how to process it and loops and all the
boring stuff
and i think it's also taking focus from
these notebooks
so let me show you like a short example
or a brief in brief because i
think um already over time anyway
i guess how we can accomplish this with
this simple
example here what do we see here this is
actually already the result
so here we read in some data
we pre-process it we put it in the
spacey pipeline
and we just want to inspect some of the
named entities so this is like a super
simple basic example i built here so
what you see
all i have to import is actually spacey
for display c
because we use display c directly here
of course i could also put this in the
class but
anyway but you see most of the stuff is
basically
comes from a custom nlp module which
imports a nice nlp class
and two more methods here and
so basically we instantiate our nice nlp
class which i'm going to show you in a
minute
and just work on it and you see this is
like a really
this is only a few lines of code uh
even to get to the first results i don't
have to scroll
at all i immediately have like a little
generator here which
provides me some examples i want to
inspect
at an early stage of a project and i can
show you like a little peek in how this
looks like of course
here's the real module uh here we have
like of course all the imports
um here we see some custom exceptions
for example we only support german and
english in our use case and if all
language identifiers just says no we
rise an exception
and this is like a really nice way um to
handle
unreliable systems like
non-english non-german data in our case
um so we write an exception we can log
it we can handle it
it's very explicit and clear um here we
see our data classes again and here you
see you can pull like a lot of extra
things in data
classes because there are classes so you
can
add methods here and here you see like
we can have
things abstracted in our nlp class and
you see for example we have our nlp
model here loaded
we have matching rules and all the stuff
and
pipeline configurations all defined as
methods
so they're easy to maintain
it's easy to read the whole pipeline is
super easy to read because it's just
like a
few function calls which i would i say
have like quite descriptive names
and also if you want to try something
new or build on that
you can use subclassing just like to
take it further
like to reuse it and um i think this is
um very important also another thing i
want to point out is
actually you've seen some
variables here like language or like
this data path of course you can
we could even go one step further and
put this in configuration files which is
here a python
dictionary actually um or it could be a
yaml file
um so yeah and so we can also like run
different experiments or
configurations and they're way easier to
configure than
if you do this in the code never put
like configurations can configurations
on parameters in code it's a really bad
practice and it's really hard to
maintain
so let's go back here
so anything else yeah tons of stuff tons
of stuff so this was
only i hope a range of half an hour talk
i will see in a second and there's
a lot of many things i mentioned type
there's other things like decomposition
also like how to
execute code in parallel um subclassing
multi-modules descriptors decorators
there's like many many things you can do
in python to make code
more readable more even more productive
but i think it's more like
a few days workshop to cover them all
and
so it's beyond the scope of this talk
but let me wrap up the main takeaways
for you
good coding is good engineering and
good engineering is an essential success
factor
for projects um so and python is
super suitable for this ah there's many
ways to achieve
a high level of coding quality without
knowing too much python actually it's
more about discipline than knowing
so much python and beyond writing
quality code there are other aspects to
consider just as personas
standardization and architecture on how
to work with each other
um and also mentors will speed up the
whole process so
don't have people just like stuck like
okay yeah you can take this online
course or you can read it online because
this is a waste of time especially
beginners
it's it's a mentor can probably easy
easily figure out what where the
misunderstanding is and clarify it like
in depth
and this can be like a 10 minute coffee
break talk
and the other way somebody could like
probably
waste half a day on solving the problem
so this is also something to consider
yeah to be mindful about people spending
time
learning this stuff it can be easier and
it can be easier with advice and
ventures
so thank you very much i hope you
enjoyed this talk
and thanks to the organizers for making
pi data global happen
um hope to see you around in person next
year all
somewhere and i also want to thank
everyone
at grindingspeak will help with those
lights and that's it
thank you very much so enjoy pi data
global and bye